figaro live il est 8h30 nous sommes en
direct sur lefigaro.fr et sur la page
youtube du figaro la page figaro live
pour commenter et débriefer les
résultats définitifs du second tour des
régionales 2021 alors pour commenter ces
résultats avec moi dans le studio et
divo train du maine bonjour bonjour
bonjour donc et divo train du maine et
directeur des études à l'institut de
sondage kantar public c'est bien ça est
avec nous dans le chat si vous nous
regardez
et bien je vous salue je vous dis
bonjour n'hésitez pas à commenter avec
nous ses résultats à nous donner vos
impressions sur ce scrutin est ce que
vous êtes allés voter hier
posez nous toutes les questions que vous
vous posez nous essaierons d'y répondre
en direct alors on va démarrer cette
session ce direct par le grand gagnant
de cette élection
ou plutôt la grande gagnante c'est
également c'est encore l'abstention
comme au premier tour
est-ce qu'on a les chiffres définitifs
de cette abstention ce matin et vous
votre un hymen pas complètement en tout
cas ce qui est certain c'est qu'on peut
on affirmer sans aucun doute un qu' il
n'y a pas eu de regain de participation
de quelques regains il a été extrêmement
léger plus un point à peu près entre le
premier et le second tour
est-ce que c'était la même dynamique
pour 2015 par exemple il y avait plus de
participation seront tous et me sens
effectivement il ya vu un regain de
participation assez net et notamment
dans des régions où est notamment paca
où il y avait des duels entre l air et
le rassemblement national ça n'a pas du
tout été le cas
cette fois ci par exemple à titre
d'exemple en paca en 2015 on a eu plus
wii points de participation entre les
deux tours
cette fois ci on a eu plus quatre points
donc deux fois moins de regain de
participation entre les deux tours alors
pourtant que la configuration est
identique
heller versus le rassemblement national
alors donc il n'y a pas eu de sursaut
démocratique se veut dire que tous les
appels de phare où les appels du pied du
du rassemblement national pour mobiliser
ses électeurs n'ont pas forcément
convaincu
est ce que c'est une défaite collective
est ce que c'est une défaite du
gouvernement sur les plateaux télé c'est
vrai que l'opposition a martelé hier
soir lors des soirées électorales que
c'était la faute du gouvernement qui
avait mal organisé ces élections qui
avaient mal communiqué autour de ces
deux scrutins
est ce qu'on peut dire que c'est la
faute incombe seulement au gouvernement
ce matin je pense que le les raisons de
cette abstention elles sont multiples
elles sont anciennes et ce que ça montre
c'est vraiment une certaine forme
d'indifférence des français à l'égard de
ce scrutin
à ne pas confondre avec l'indifférence à
l'égard de la politique parce que
lorsqu'on interroge les français
justement sur leur intérêt pour la
politique ça fait un certain nombre de
mois où justement cet intérêt il
augmente donc attention à ne pas faire
des raccourcis trop important mais ce
que ça veut dire c'est que les français
finalement ils ont pas compris les
enjeux ou n'ont pas voulu les comprendre
parce que on cette dernière semaine on a
parlé de régionales on pourra pas dire
qu'il ait un problème d'information
on aurait pu le supposer c'est une
hypothèse qui était faite au premier
tour c'est absolument pas une hypothèse
qui était validée vu les chiffres de la
participation au second tour
ça montre aussi que finalement les
français ils sont en train de se dire
non seulement qu'ils ont de la peine et
ce qu'on voit dans les études à avoir
l'impact de leur vote dans leur vie
quotidienne c'est à dire qu'on ne
comprend pas aujourd'hui qu'est ce que
ça veut dire de voter pour un candidat
aux régionales au départemental ses deux
premiers points
le deuxième point c'est que il ya un
certain nombre de français qui ont le
sentiment aujourd'hui que finalement ce
qui fait un peu la colonne vertébrale de
la vie politique française c'est
l'élection présidentielle et que
finalement c'est au tour de cette
élection là qu'ils sont majeurs la vème
république que les français se
mobilisent
et de fait ils ont tendance à se
désintéresser des élections
intermédiaires c'était le cas aux
municipales c'était qu'elle régionales
et puis enfin peut-être troisième point
c'est finalement on peut se demander
s'il ya un problème d'offre politique
c'est à dire qu'au delà de l'intérêt
pour cette élection là pour ces
élections intermédiaires l'a peut-être
aussi que les français c'est ce qu'ils
nous disent aussi dans un certain nombre
d'études ils ne se reconnaissent plus
dans l'offre politique il aurait proposé
à l'échelon local notamment
alors si vous nous rejoignez nous sommes
en direct donc sur lefigaro.fr et sur
notre page youtube figaro live pour
commenter et débriefer les résultats
définitifs de ce second tour des
régionales
d'ailleurs sur le chat du figaro donc si
vous me voyez regarder assez souvent mon
ordinateur c'est parce que je vous lis
je vous regarde je vois vos commentaires
il y à matteo sur le chat de youtube qui
qui donne un commentaire et qui explique
pourquoi donc s'il n'est pas allé voter
je vais le lire si la droite patriote et
souverainistes ne veut plus aller voter
c'est parce que le système est pourri et
parce que la démocratie est faible et
stérile et là il lance donc une
proposition donc à la présidente du fn
j'imagine alors il faut qu'elle assume
et qu'elle fasse un putsch et dit votre
un domaine on peut peut-être déjà parlé
donc du rn avec ce commentaire
est-ce que là le fn et marine le pen
donc a échoué dans sa stratégie de
dédiabolisation du rassemblement
national
la question est la situation du rn elle
est extrêmement ambigu parce que ce qui
faisait le succès en place qui faisait
une partie du succès du rn c'était
justement ce vote anti système
c'est aussi pour ça qu'un certain nombre
de français se tourner vers eux parce
qu'ils considéraient qu à droite à
gauche verts n'avaient pas marché et que
de fait seul le rn était capable de
porter leur voix or le problème
aujourd'hui c'est que le rn a besoin
d'élargir son cercle électoral
et de faire sauter ce qu'on appelle
parfois en sciences politiques le
plafond de verre est la question qui se
pose aujourd'hui c'est justement comment
faire sauter ce plafond de verre comment
élargir justement c'est ce socle
électoral tout en incarnant encore cet
anti système justement ce parti
politique fait la politique autrement
et là c'est un dilemme qui est
extrêmement compliquée pour marine le
pen c'est à dire quand elle est trop
anti système on dit ouh là là mais vous
voyez elle n'est pas crédible c'est un
peu ce qui s'est passé avec le duel avec
emmanuel macron lors de la précédente
présidentielle et en même temps
lorsqu'elle est trop établi entre
guillemets ben justement elle perd une
partie de ses électeurs donc c'est
extrêmement compliqué justement de jouer
sur dédiabolisation versus crédibilité
et posture présidentielle notamment dans
la perspective de 2022 alors justement
on va on va écouter la présidente du
rassemblement national qui s'est exprimé
hier soir on écoute tout de suite marine
le pen chasse totale d'information mais
organisation désastreuse et l'erratique
des scrutins par le ministère de
l'intérieur
la sortie d'un interminable confinement
un désenchantement à l'égard des
élections intermédiaires que le civisme
et la lucidité des électeurs du rn qui a
apporté leurs voix à nos candidats soit
loué ce soir nous ne parlerons pas de
région puisque des sortants à l'aide d'
alliances contre nature ont tous fait
vous empêcher de montrer aux français
notre capacité à diriger un exécutif
régional
la progression très importante entre les
deux tours en paca qui reste tout de
même insuffisante pour offrir la
victoire démontre que la mobilisation
est la clé des victoires à venir
nombreuse élu ce soir défendrons par
tous les intérêts des habitants avec un
mot d'ordre vous protéger et lorsque
deux français sur trois persiste à ne
pas voter en particulier les jeunes et
les classes populaires c'est évidemment
un message qui doit nous interpeller car
cette désaffection civique historique
constitue un signal majeur lancé à toute
la classe politique et même à toute la
société
nous vivons une crise profonde de la
démocratie locale qui nécessite un
travail de réflexion
rectif méthodes de mobilisation
représentativité informations des
électeurs proportionnelle référendum
d'initiative citoyenne
tout doit être aujourd'hui débattu pour
rendre à nos compatriotes le goût de
décider de leur avenir
je suis plus que jamais déterminé à
mettre toute mon énergie et ma volonté à
réhabiliter la politique à lui rendre
son utilité et son efficacité au
bénéfice des français
parce que la présidentielle apparaît
plus que jamais comme l'élection qui
permet de changer de politique et de
changer les politiques et que les
français nous apportent leur soutien
dans cette mission je donne rendez vous
aux français
dès demain pour construire tous ensemble
l'alternance dont la france a besoin oui
alors vous avez entendu donc marine le
pen parler d'une désaffection civique
majeur et divo train du maine est ce
qu'on peut revenir un peu sur le profil
de ces abstentionnistes du second tour
est ce que ce sont les mêmes qu'au
premier tour effectivement ce sont les
mêmes alors d'une manière générale la
participation où l'abstention a été
la même entrepreniez second tour et ce
qui est intéressant c'est que il y
compris les publics qui d'habitude se
mobilise beaucoup les retraités les plus
de 65 ans se sont beaucoup moins
beaucoup moins mobilisé cette fois ci ça
c'est le premier élément deuxième
élément c'est que aujourd'hui on a entre
eux ça dépend il faudra qu'on attende
les derniers les dernières études post
électorale mais on a à priori moins de
15 % des moins de 25 ans qui se sont
mobilisés ce que ça veut dire
concrètement cette élection elle aura
été faite essentiellement par les
seniors et elle aura exclu quasiment
plus des trois quarts des moins de 25
ans et la jeunesse donc ça pose un vrai
problème et si vous voulez on voit ici
des fractures exacerbée par rapport à ce
que l'on voit d'habitude c'est pas
nouveau les jeunes votent toujours -
eddy seigneur veut toujours plus mais là
si vous voulez tout a été amplifiée y
compris chez des gens qui d'habitude
voter encore une fois parce qu'en fait
tout le monde a été obnubilé par ce
scrutin
d'après qui est celui la présidentielle
est ce que on sait si c'est vraiment le
rn qui se retrouvent pénalisés par cette
abstention ou d'autres partis ont perdu
en perdu à cause de cette abstention
alors le rn effectivement a subi cette
extension parce que la sociologie
électorale du r n est bien singulière on
sait que ce sont généralement des
catégories sociales défavorisées que ce
sont des gens peu diplômés et que ce
sont des gens plutôt jeune or d'habitude
on observe sur l'ensemble des élections
ce sont des publics qui se mobilise
beaucoup moins dense dans les élections
et peu importe le niveau des élections
effectivement c'est intéressant je peux
leur à son nom nationale que de
mobiliser ses troupes
hélas ce que l'on a observé c'est que
ces troubles ne se sont pas mobilisés et
c'est sans doute pour le rn que ça a été
le plus compliqué le plus dommageable et
est ce que cette abstention était
prévisible au regard des sondages en
sait que pour le premier tour donc les
sondeurs les instituts de sondage ont
été mises à mal parce qu'il n'avait pas
anticipé une telle démobilisation
des citoyens français est ce que là
entre entre les deux tours vous avez été
plus prudent où vous avez bien estimé
cette abstention
alors la question de l'estimation de
l'abstention elle a été extrêmement
compliqué mais on a commencé à voir des
signes parce que la semaine d'avant le
scrutin
il ya quelques enquêtes qui ont été
publiés et d'autres confidentiel qui
tirait déjà la sonnette d'alarmé en
disant attention l'abstention serait
autour des 60 % dans un scrutin qui
finalement intéressé assez peu les
français avec des enjeux régionaux qui
avait assez peu été évoquée on sait que
une dynamique de campagne et derniers
jours peut exister
donc on savait qu'elle serait haute on
savait pas exactement à quel niveau on
ne pensait pas qu'elle serait aussi hot
pourra totalement transparent mais
néanmoins on sentait que les français
n'allait pas se mobiliser en masse
et c'est justement toute la difficulté
des sondages pré électoraux c'est d'être
capable de voir quelles vont être les
français qui vont se mobiliser c'est ce
qu'on appelle la participation
l'abstention différencier c'est à dire
on sait que peu de français vont aller
voter mais on a du mal à voir quels sont
les français qui vont se mobiliser et
quels sont les français qui ne ment pas
se mobiliser et c'est typiquement ce qui
s'est passé pour le rassemblement
national ou en fait on a pu voir et on
confirmera par des études que ce sont
des électeurs mais pas que durera son
nationale qui se sont moins mobilisés
que les autres et que par rapport au
précédent scrutin
alors si vous nous rejoignez comme
bernard bon sens sur le cha du figaro.fr
bonjour avoue bernard bon sens qui nous
dit bonjour
macron a détruit ce pays et il a déçu la
jeunesse il doit dissoudre l'agent la
chambre ce gouvernement n'a aucune
légitimité
ce qui est ce qui m'amène donc sur les
rails pour une question pour vous a dit
votre 1 du maine c'est la grosse débâcle
pour le gouvernement
est ce qu'on peut faire un point donc
sur cet échec colossal abyssal
du parti de la majorité effectivement
c'est un échec
c'est assez clair pour tout le monde
pour les français mais aussi sans doute
pour le gouvernement et sa montre encore
une fois toute la difficulté pour la
république en marche 200 créée
localement
ce que ça montre aussi sa a signé 10
c'est vraiment cette déconnexion entre
la vie politique locale où le ps et les
républicains existe malgré tout et on
l'a bien vu à l'issue de ces régionales
et la politique nationale où pour le
coup on nous parle d'un duel
l'appliquant marche le rn qui sont
pourtant les deux perdants ces
régionales
donc effectivement c'est une débâcle
pour la réplique en marche à la poser de
vraies questions notamment dans la
perspective de 2022 parce qu'il va
falloir réussir à créer une dynamique
mais comment il crée une dynamique alors
qu'on a montré aux municipales et aux
régionales que finalement on avait du
mal à comprendre et à recevoir
finalement les attentes des français à
l'échelon local dans les territoires
alors justement le parti donc la
république en marche le parti de la
majorité gouvernementale est arrivée en
quatrième position je crois donc après
évidemment l air le ps et le fn
avec à peine 7% des voix et au second
tour il est où il était arrivé le
candidat de la majorité est toujours
arrivé en dernière position il me semble
sauf en avant dernière position en
bretagne je crois donc c'est vraiment
une claque après celles des municipales
est ce que vous pensez on a entendu hier
selon des sources concordantes de la
presse que le gouffre un mac ronald
n'envisagez pas du tout de remanier
est-ce que vous pensez que c'est une
bonne stratégie une bonne réponse de
macron de ne pas entendre cette claque
je pense que les français concrètement
ça ne les intéresse pas finalement cette
question du remaniement ou pas
les françaises qui se dit c'est que ils
font confiance à leurs élus locaux ils
ont dit aux municipales ils ont dit aux
régionales et ce qu'ils demandent au
gouvernement c'est de réformer la france
en tout cas ce les gens qui ont voté
manuel da cruz des ce qui évidement donc
finalement c'est ce qu'on voit aussi
dans nos études il n'y a pas de fortes
attentes à tirer des leçons en tout cas
il est franchement pas sentiment que
parce qu'il est un échec aux régionales
et aux municipales avant le gouvernement
entend tirer des conséquences musique
très très très net et c'est assez nette
aussi parce que justement lorsqu'on a
interrogé les français
juste avant le premier tour ce qui me
disaient les français c'est que
finalement il n'avait pas envie dans
cette campagne dans ton de parler
d'alliance électorale de politique ce
qui les intéressait c'était de voir
comment est-ce que ce vote là allaient
impacter leur vie quotidienne
donc le risque justement du gouvernement
si jamais il devait annoncer un
remaniement c'est finalement de se
remettre dans une tactique très
politicienne finalement et d'oublier
finalement le peu de capital qui lui
reste c'est sa capacité encore à
réformer la france donc finalement
peut-être que le cheval entre le choix
du remaniement et le choix justement
d'affirmer la nécessité et la volonté du
gouvernement de faire des réformes de
continuité des réformes
a priori on pressent le gouvernement
serait plutôt de sur cette option là
parce que justement il a sans doute
compris que c'était la seule manière
justement de créer la dynamique et de
d'arriver encore à créer l'adhésion en
vis-à-vis de son projet alors chantal la
goutte qui nous rejoint sur le chat du
figaro.fr et qui nous dit bonjour à tous
et quel échec cuisant pour macron
effectivement nous sommes en train d'en
débattre et de décrypter les pauvres
résultats les maigres résultats de la
république en marche à ce second tour
bernard bon sens qui continue de chatter
et je l'en remercie sur le sur
lefigaro.fr qui nous dit macron ne veut
pas admettre son échec
il ne veut pas écouter les français on
en vient donc encore à cette question
est ce que vraiment le remaniement vous
dites que les français ne s'y intéresse
pas mais on voit dans le chat qui
devrait quand même peut-être prendre au
moins la parole ou mesurer cet échec
enfin admettre l'échec peut-être qu'il
faut je pense qu'être deux choses
différentes et c'est très juste ce qui
est dit dans le commentaire c'est que
finalement écouté les français ça ne se
traduit pas forcément par un remaniement
est effectivement la réponse d'un
remaniement elle pourrait être mal
interprété ou mal comprise par les
français en revanche effectivement il ya
sans doute une nécessité pour
gouvernement et poèmes manuellement
parce que c'est quand même très incarné
un par la figure du président de la
république de prendre la parole et de
finalement donner des gages sur la
capacité qu'il a qu'à son gouvernement à
comprendre les problèmes des français à
rendre possible une projection dans
l'avenir qui sont un peu plus positive
notamment dans ce contexte de sortie
très donc effectivement la question de
l' écoute des français et la capacité à
apporter des réponses aux angoisses
qu'ils expriment au fil des scrutins est
extrêmement importante et sera un des
enjeux justement de 2022 alors on va
faire un petit focus on va se focaliser
donc sur une région particulière qui
était très attendue pour ce second tour
c'est la région paca donc avec renaud
muselier qui était en ballottage assez
défavorables et qui était le président
ait l'air sortant et qui a finalement en
privé le rassemblement de sa seule
potentielle victoire en fait donc à
pardon excusez moi et donc là on peut
aussi expliquer que les sondages de
l'entre-deux tours pour le coup n'était
pas n'ont pas vraiment viser juste pour
cette fois ci parce que muselier l'a
emporté d'une très nette victoire cette
fois ci effectivement ce que ce que ça
veut dire c'est finalement le front
républicain il marche encore en tout cas
il a marché encore en paca et ça fait ça
faisait partie pardon des inconnus
justement de ce second tour c'était est
ce que parce que c'est comme la deuxième
fois que ça arrive en paca est ce que
les électeurs finalement notamment les
électeurs de gauche vont encore une fois
se mobiliser et vont encore accepter que
la gauche ne soit pas représenté au
conseil régional est elle une dizaine
s'intitule c'est l'une des raisons pour
lesquelles justement les sondages
avaient du mal à mesurer ce rapport de
force
et force est de constater qu'il a
fonctionné et que de fait ça a
fonctionné pour renaud muselier qui fait
mieux qu'en 2015
il faut à peu près deux points de plus
qu'au précédent scrutin alors on voit
les résultats définitifs qui se sont
affichées sur sur notre antenne de 56,3
pour le président sortant l air renaud
muselier et 44,7 pour le candidat du
rassemblement national
est ce qu'on peut dire que c'est un
échec pour le coup pour le rassemblement
national ça c'est bien sûr mais est ce
que le rassemblement national comme le
parti présidentiel doit prendre la
mesure de cet échec
on a entendu tout à l'heure donc marine
le pen qui qui clairement affiche sa
volonté de
de maintenir sa campagne est de rester
en campagne elle appelle les français à
se mobiliser dès à présent pour 2022
mais ce qui a pas des ajustements à
prévoir aussi qui est certain c'est que
la victoire d'une région aurait aurait
été symbolique et aurait pu enclencher
une dynamique ou en tout cas accélérer
une dynamique dans la perspective de
dans la perspective pardon de 2022
ce qui est intéressant lorsqu'on regarde
ses résultats et sa capacité d'url mais
aussi finalement la république en marche
c'est que ce duel encore une fois que
l'on annonce pour 2022 il est
aujourd'hui dans la difficulté de s'en
créer localement et de prouver si vous
voulez sa capacité à gouverner des
régions au budget de la plusieurs
milliards d'euros de montrer qu'au delà
des communes ce que le fn avait réussi à
faire attention mais qu'il est capable
finalement de gérer des collectivités
territoriales qu'il est capable de
connaître des territoires de s'appuyer
sur une vraie expertise et sur une vraie
connaissance des territoires en france
et force est de constater qu'aujourd'hui
le rn comme l'appliquant marche a du mal
justement à passer l'étape d'après qui
est celui de s'ancrer localement avec
l'obtention et le gain de d'exécutifs
locaux
alors jean michel lu marx sur le chat du
figaro.fr nous a rejoint et abondent
dans votre sens a dit votre un dumas n'y
ai dit bonjour ce ne sont que ce sont
des élections régionales
et ce ne sont pas des élections
nationales comment parler d'échec de la
république en marche pour un mouvement
qui existe que depuis quatre ans et qui
n'est donc pas implantés localement donc
ça va dans votre sens et ça m'amène
justement à une autre partie donc de ce
direct pour aborder donc la grande
victoire des partis traditionnels en
fait finalement c'est le ps et les
républicains qui sortent grands
vainqueurs
si tenté qu'il ya beaucoup d'abstention
mais qui sortent quand même grand
vainqueur de ce second tour
effectivement et c'est le et c'est
finalement le résultat de la prime au
sortant
les français ce que je disais tout à
l'heure un finalement ils avaient envie
était déjà au départ pas très intéressé
par cette élection et finalement ils ont
voté pour ceux qui le connaissaient ils
ont voté pour les gens finalement qui
parlait des problèmes de la région qui
parlait du programme et d'un projet
politique pour la région est finalement
assez peu à la lecture finalement ou
plutôt avec des arguments qui aurait été
lié à la politique nationale donc
effectivement il ya une prime aux
sortants qui a extrêmement important qui
vaut à gauche dans une moindre mesure et
puis surtout à droite parce que et pour
les républicains
parce que c'est eux qui possèdent
beaucoup de régions mais effectivement
c'était c'est assez nette
et ça montre aussi encore une fois que
les français il s'intéresse aussi aux
scrutins lorsqu'on leur parle des enjeux
qui les intéressent et en l'occurrence
parler de 2022 et parler de stratégie
électorale ou d'alliance entre les
républicains et la réplique en marche
finalement et ben ça les a pas
intéressés ils l'ont montré de manière
assez claire en allant pas voter ce qui
fait dire parfois même à certains que
cette extension elle peut être militante
et on peut se demander justement si dans
un certain nombre de régions les
français ne sont pas 10 mais finalement
pourquoi aller voter alors qu'on parle
de stratégie politique alors que moi ce
qui m'intéresse c'est les lycées c'est
les transports alors même que ses
domaines de compétences sont un peu
flous 1 mais est ce que vous pensez
vraiment que les français soient
intéressés par les transports et les
lycées pas tout ça pas tous bien
évidemment mais en tout cas ce qui est
certain c'est qu'ils n'ont pas envie
qu'on leur parle de 2022 en permanence
ou que l'on parle de stratégie
électorale
ça c'est certain après effectivement le
tout ce qui est lié aux compétences et
ski ski en plus en france et pas simple
entre les mairies les collectivités
territoriales les départements et les
régions effectivement c'est pas
forcément évident pour tout le monde je
suis totalement d'accord avec vous mais
néanmoins ce qui est certain c'est
qu'ils veulent pas qu'on leur parle
toujours de nationalité 2022 c'est là
dessus il ya aucun doute et on le voit
assez nettement dans nos études
alors justement si on fait un petit
focus sur sur les partis traditionnels
qui sortent un peu vainqueur c'est là
c'est la droite qui arrive en tête et
qui relève la tête à l'échelle nationale
elle s'affirme donc comme le premier
parti la première force politique avec
38% des voix
est ce que le bon score de la droite est
ce que le bon score des républicains
notamment
et convertibles pour la présidentielle
alors ça c'est la réponse elle est à la
fois du côté des français mais elle est
aussi et surtout du côté des
républicains et leur capacité à dégager
un candidat unique et qui ferait
consensus autour de lui ce qui est clair
et ce qui est assez net depuis les
municipales et qu'ils aient confirmé aux
régionales c'est que les républicains
ont une assise dans les territoires dans
les collectivités territoriales qui est
extrêmement importante
là dessus il ya aucun doute de là à ce
que ça se traduise en dynamique
électorale pour 2022 les choses sont
extrêmement compliqué et on l'a bien vu
hier que ce soit surtout xavier bertrand
et laurent wauquiez dans une moindre
mesure mais quand même valérie pécresse
de suite se sont lancés si vous voulez
dans la perspective de 2022 donc
attention effectivement il ya des bons
résultats mais il faudrait pas non plus
que la droite retombe dans ses vieux
démons qui serait finalement la querelle
des chefs donc finalement il suffit pas
d'avoir des bons et des bons résultats
dans des élections intermédiaires pour
ensuite gagner des élections gagnent au
contraire alors justement vous avez
évoqué donc les les trois ténors donc de
cette droite qui sont sortis tous
vainqueurs qui étaient sortants donc
déjà en place dans leur région et qui
sont tous sortis largement en tête à la
fois du premier tour mais aussi du
second tour
on les écoute tous les trois
les hauts de france m'ont fait l'honneur
de m'accorder à nouveau leur confiance
durant cette campagne je vous ai dit la
vérité
j'ai été clair sans rien vous cacher de
mes intentions
ce résultat me donne la force d'aller à
la rencontre de tous les français pour
redresser notre pays
il y à un préalable le rétablissement de
l'ordre et du respect l'insécurité mines
la république la défigure et ce sont les
plus modestes les premières victimes
ce soir une équipe de france de la
droite et du centre a émergé dans les
régions nous avons une grande
responsabilité et j'y prendrai toute ma
part plus que jamais je veux continuer
et amplifier mon combat pour mes
convictions mais aussi pour les valeurs
de la république
des concerts espérer quand on ne réagit
pas par rapport à ceux qui dégradent la
france ce soir les extrêmes ont reculé
fortement dans notre région car nous ne
leur laisserons aucun terrain pour
prospérer
je les dis
peut-être un prétendant possible à 2022
qui est lui le candidat ait l'air qui a
fait le plus le plus grand score dans la
région auvergne rhône-alpes avec 57,17 %
face une liste face à une liste d'union
de la gauche
et puis on a tendu on a entendu juste
avant donc valérie pécresse en
ile-de-france qui a récolté autour des
45 % de voix il me semble face à la
liste de la gauche unie encore emmenée
par l'écologiste julien bayou est-ce
qu'on peut revenir du coup sûr sûr sûr
cette région importante qui est la
région de la capitale de la france la
région ile de france
est-ce que c'était évident pour valérie
pécresse de remporter ce scrutin
elles étaient dans une situation
relativement confortable depuis le
depuis le début de sa campagne elle
avait un bilan plutôt favorable ce que
nous lisez les français dans les
inquiète qu'on pouvait mener
et puis elle avait face à elle aussi une
gauche qui étaient relativement divisés
avec les écologistes les insoumis et le
parti socialiste qui a eu du mal
d'ailleurs pour ce dernier à faire
décoller dans sap à décoller un mail à
sa campagne électorale donc finalement
elle elle a réussi à conserver sa région
ce qui est ce qui est ce qui est
symbolique mais ce qui va encore une
fois dans le sens de la prime aux
sortants et qu'on a observés ailleurs
et puis ce qui est intéressant aussi
c'est de regarder finalement qu'est-ce
qui s'est passé à gauche et qu'est ce
que cette union de la gauche qui a été
fait qui était réalisée entre le premier
second tour est là elle a généré comme
dynamique et en fait ce que l'on observe
c'est qu'effectivement c'était l'une des
questions qu'on se posait au départ il
n'y a pas eu de déperdition des lecteurs
justement donc concrètement c'est à dire
que des électeurs de gauche n'ont pas eu
peur d'une alliance le lvps france
insoumise
alors que c'était une question qu'on se
posait dans l'entre-deux tours mais ce
que l'on voit aussi c'est finalement
leur score correspond à l'addition peu
ou prou de leur score au premier tour ce
que ça veut dire donc c'est que cette
alliance de la gauche n'a pas réussi
justement à créer une dynamique qui
auraient été capables de renverser
valérie pécresse qui finalement est lui
un peu mieux qu'en 2015 et donc conserve
son poste à la tête de la région
capitale
alors justement dans le tchat sur
lefigaro.fr vous êtes nombreux à
débattre donc des chances l air pour les
présidentielles je vais vous lire je
vais lire un peu vos commentaires pour
que les personnes qui nous suivent sur
youtube
soit au courant alors jean-michel marx
nous dit il ne faut pas s'enflammer la
droite n'a aucune chance aux
présidentielles bernard bon sens
également abonde en dix ans l heure ne
réussira pas aux présidentielles car
effectivement il y aura querelles et
divisions entre les ténors de la droite
avec peut-être sarkozy en embuscade
probus qui est nouveau dans le chat et
que je salue nous dit seuls wauquiez a
la carrure pour les présidentielles et
jean-michel remarks de conclure allez
bertrand pécresse évoqué un peu
d'humilité sinon cela ça cela cela va
faire mal en 2022
est ce que la droite a raison d'y croire
pour 2022 est ce qu on a déjà des
sondages
présidentiel où se positionne à la
droite dans ses sondages face à macro et
le pen par exemple alors entre ce que
l'on observe dans les dernières
intentions de vote qui ont été réalisés
là mais qui n'ont pas été réalisés du
coup après le second tour donc il faudra
voir ce que ça donne d'ici une semaine
il ya une légère dynamique pour la
candidature bertrand est ce qu'il faut
avoir en tête justement dans la
perspective 2022 c'est que déjà la
campagne n'a pas commencé et que donc il
faut être extrêmement prudent parce que
tout peut se passer
on l'a déjà vu un lors des précédents
scrutins que les dynamiques de campagne
pouvait aller vite et pouvait surtout
être surprenante mais il ya vraiment
deux conditions je pense qu'ils sont
importantes pour un succès des
républicains c'est d'abord d'être
capable de dégager un consensus au sein
de sa famille politique pour le candidat
qui sera qui portera les couleurs et
l'air
c'est à dire concrètement qu'il faudra
que ce candidat là eh ben il soit
légitimé et massivement légitimé par
rapport à elles des républicains que
finalement ces querelles et ses
divisions
elle ne soit pas trop visible et qu'elle
arrive à être qu'elle arrive à être
englobée dans la candidature qui sera
faite c'est le premier point
et puis le deuxième point c'est la
capacité à rassembler au second tour
parce qu'on sait que ça se passe comme
ça une campagne électorale il faut si
vous voulez mobiliser son camp au
premier tour et puis rassembler pour le
second tour et l'âme c'est sans doute
l'une des forces de cette année bertrand
et c'est là où ça peut pêcher pour
laurent wauquiez c'est qu' il faudrait
une personnalité qui sera qui ne serait
pas trop clivante justement pour être
capable d'élargir son socle électoral
pour le second tour il ça pour le coup
c'est l'une des forces de cette bertrand
c'est de pouvoir aller chercher un peu à
gauche beaucoup au centre et bien
entendu à droite pour espérer l'emporter
au second tour même si encore une fois
tout ça reste au conditionnel il soumis
à la dynamique de campagne et à la
campagne électorale en soi est soumis
également à l'abstention et au retour
des abstentionnistes comme nous le
signale jean michel marques dans le chat
surtout n'oublions pas que deux tiers
des français n'ont pas voté
effectivement alors on va désormais
aborder
la question du parti socialiste et on va
démarrer donc on va écouter la grande
vainqueur donc des régionales c'est une
femme et c'est elle qui a eut obtenu le
plus grand score c'est carole delga
l'élue sortante ps en occitanie on va
écouter tout de suite son discours de
victoire ce soir
l'occitanie a fait un choix clair celui
de la force celui du rassemblement et de
l'action autour de valeurs positives et
ambitieuse le progrès la justice sociale
la solidarité l'écologie l'innovation la
fraternité alors un sincère un immense
merci au peuple d'occitanie je
n'oublierai pas cette marque de
confiance
elle me donne encore plus de gnac pour
me battre pour vous que vous ayez voté
ou non comme je lai toujours fait je me
battrai pour vous avec éthique avec
courage et fidélité merci à toutes et à
tous
voilà on vient d'entendre donc carole
delga qui a remporté la région occitanie
et qui n'était associé ni à la france un
soumise ni au vert et c'est important de
le souligner effectivement c'était le
chaos s'ils renouvellent aquitaine ce
qu'on voit c'est que lorsque le ps est
solidement ancrée et un dans sa région
lorsqu'il a un bilan à défendre parce
qu'encore une fois les résultats et le
niveau de satisfaction à l'égard du
bilan régional de carole delga et été
très largement positif 1 mais finalement
le ps arrive à à gagner des élections
ce qui pose de fait la question ou ski
plutôt ne résout pas la question du
leadership à gauche c'est à dire que le
ps est encore en capacité de gagner des
élections régionales dans des régions
qui ne sont pas petit l'occitanie la
nouvelle aquitaine donc ça monte
finalement que le ps existe encore là où
il est ancré localement
là où il est capable d'être clair sur un
certain nombre de sujets on l'a beaucoup
dit en occitanie sur le rapport aux à
l'extrême gauche sur la laïcité etc
donc ça montre finalement que le ps
n'est pas mort et qu'il existe encore en
tout cas à minima dans certains
territoires
et est ce que cette union des gauches à
fonctionner finalement ben finalement
pas tant que ça parce que lorsque le ps
était seul et qui était solidement
ancrée nouvelle a quitté d'occitanie il
a réussi à gagner est finalement lorsque
le ps et alliés avec les écologistes
comme ça a été le cas et la france 1
soumise comme ça a été le cas en ile de
france
finalement ça n'a pas su créer de
dynamique donc ce que ça montre c'est
finalement que cette union de la gauche
elle n'est pas forcément synonyme de
victoire en tout cas les peines elle se
traduit pas toujours par une dynamique
dans les yeux et ça montre aussi
finalement qu'il ya encore des éléments
de différenciation assez nette entre la
gauche accède gauche elle reste
plurielle et elle n'arrive pas encore à
s'unir autour d'un programme qui
pourrait créer une dynamique de campagne
donc effectivement c'est extrêmement
compliqué parce que certains espéraient
que ces régionales même si encore une
fois c'est un scrutin local puisse
apporter des questions ou des éléments
de réponse plutôt sur le leadership de
la gauche est ce que ça serait plutôt
comme on avait pu le penser aux
municipales derrière un candidat
écologiste
finalement la réponse elle est loin
d'être claire l'issue du scrutin
alors on voit que les ténors de la
droite qui ont gagné des régions se sont
tout de suite a à demi mot pour certain
et carrément voire carrément prononcés
pour pour 2022
en revanche donc 7,7 carole delga est
également monsieur rousset un nouvel
aquitaine n'ont pas fait de même
pourquoi pourquoi le ps ne prend pas ces
victoires et comme gage pour 2022 parce
que la différence
à la différence du ps aujourd'hui c'est
qu'il n'y aurait pas faim il n'y a pas
de candidat qui ferait qui ferait
l'unanimité ou qui ferait consensus si
vous allez au sein du parti socialiste
est sans doute que la première ambition
la première nécessité du ps est d'abord
finalement de conserver son ancrage
territorial
on sait le ps en 2015 a perdu énormément
de région et donc là c'est important
pour lui s'il veut continuer d'exister
au niveau national a minima de garder un
certain nombre de mairies et de régions
donc c'est sans doute finalement si vous
voulez la condition nécessaire à son
existence future
une fois que ce point là il aura été
consolidées il aurait été acquis
effectivement se posera la question de
2022 or encore une fois et c'est un peu
la même chose qu'à droite il n'y a pas
de personnalité et c'est encore ça c'est
encore plus compliqué qu'à droite même
il ya pas de personnalité qui arrive à
dégager un consensus donc pente pour
l'instant il vaut sans doute mieux pour
le ps de se concentrer sur ces régions
là pour ensuite peut-être voir s'il ya
une personnalité qui fait consensus mais
on en est encore loin
alors philippe dardenne qui nous a
rejoints sur le chat de youtube sur
notre page figaro live bonjour philippe
dernier qui déclarent en conclusion les
sondages se sont déjà trompés pour ces
élections intermédiaires avant les
présidentielles
certes l erp devront faire l'union
autour d'un même candidat est ce que
c'est la vérité est ce que les sondages
se sont trompés oui on a beaucoup parlé
d erreurs de son âge du premier tour
est-ce que là pour le second tour vous
avez visé juste plus tôt alors ce qu'il
faut être il faut être extrêmement
prudent sur le sur la lecture qu'on fait
des sondages
effectivement là de manière théorique en
dit les sondages n'ont pas de valeur
prédictive ce qui montre aussi
finalement toute l'humilité et toute la
modestie qu'il faut avoir lorsqu'en
justement on présente des chiffres c'est
à dire que effectivement cette
photographie à un instant t
et il faut bien avoir en tête que une
dynamique de campagne peut se mettre en
place et qu' il peut y avoir une
différence entre
une intention de vote et des résultats
électoraux mais encore une fois ce qui
est très important d'avoir en tête c'est
que lorsqu'on a quasiment les deux tiers
des français qui se mobilisent pas en
fait on reste dans la marge d'erreur est
finalement ça explique aussi que les
sondages ne t'ont pas juste parce qu'on
ne sait pas qui va aller voter au qui ne
veut pas aller voter et finalement à
quelques voix près ça peut faire
basculer une élection ou pas ce qui
n'est pas du tout le cas pour l'élection
présidentielle où pour le coup on a plus
de 80% des français qui vont voter donc
effectivement sur des élections locales
il ya des enjeux méthodologiques qui va
falloir justement question en tant que
sondeurs et c'est ce qu'on fait en
permanence
en revanche pour la perspective de 2022
je pense qu'on peut être assez confiant
tout en étant humble encore une fois est
modeste sur la lecture qu'on peut faire
des résultats mais encore une fois ce
qu'il faut aussi avoir en tête c'est une
campagne électorale c'est une dynamique
et que les sondages ils sont là pour
venir
si vous voulez illustrer cette dynamique
là mais c'est pas eux qui vont faire
l'élection et donc c'est aussi pour ça
que les sondages peuvent différer des
résultats finaux donc il faut les lire
pour ce qu'ils sont et puis il faut
aussi regarder justement comment est-ce
que ensuite la dynamique de campagne
peut faire bouger les choses et bien
entendu l'issue du scrutin alors chantal
la goutte sur le chat du figaro.fr nous
parle de je pense
emmanuel macron en disant il arrivera
bien à casser la droite tout comme il
l'a fait pour d'autres partis
alors méfiance il ya également mérou 63
qui nous demandent pourquoi ne parler
que des pourcentages et non des voix qui
l'ont obtenu
est ce que c'est vrai est ce qu'on est
ce qu'on peut transcrire ça est-ce que
vous avez ces chiffres là ou pas du tout
par rapport à l'abstention c'est vrai
que ça pourrait changer un peu notre
vision canton quand on dit que xavier
bertrand a remporté 50 2,37 pour cent
des voix est ce qu'on sait ce que cela
représente en nombre numéraire si on
peut on peut le on peut le savoir et
c'est quelque chose qu'on fera une fois
qu'on aura les résultats définitifs du
missel intérieur effectivement c'est
important de
de se dire ces chiffres et pareil pour
l'abstention parce que finalement quand
on dit 66% des français ne sont pas
allés voter oui mais qu'est ce que ça
représente 5,2 millions d'électeurs donc
effectivement c'est extrêmement
important et ça peut permettre justement
aux français de se matérialiser de ce
que ça correspond ces chiffres et ce
sont des données qu'on a qui sont
disponibles ailleurs pour tout le monde
sur le site du ministère l'intérieur une
fois que les résultats sont consolidés
donc ça sera d'ici demain ou après
demain jean-michel marx qui nous demande
qui nous dit les jeunes n'ont pas voté
effectivement et auront leur poids pour
les présidentielles
est ce que c'est vrai ce que les jeunes
se mobilisent davantage pour les
élections présidentielles alors
effectivement les jeunes en pas voter
effectivement les jeunes se mobilisent
davantage pour l'élection présidentielle
mais encore une fois il se mobilise
toujours moins que l'ensemble des
français
on a toujours eu une participation qui
bien qu'ils aient bien en deçà du niveau
moyen
en revanche et un troisième point qu'il
faut avoir en tête c'est qu'aujourd'hui
le corps électoral français et plutôt
âgés et ça correspond finalement à la
sociologie française donc même si les
jeunes vont davantage voté à l'élection
présidentielle que ce qu'ils ont fait
pour l'élection régionale
face à ce constat sté force est de
constater pardon que dans tous les cas
ils sont bien moins nombreux dans le
corps électoral que les 65 ans et plus
bernard bon sens qui répond à ce que
nous disons et espérons qu'ils aillent
voter car sans la mobilisation de la
jeunesse
un pays ne vaut rien est ce qu'on sait
déjà à peu près pour qu'ils votent votre
ces jeunes on a une photographie un peu
de leurs intentions de vote en tout cas
pour la présidentielle ce que vous avez
déjà réalisé 10 ha oui alors pour pour
le pour la présidentielle on s'est
plutôt ces jeunes alors il faut il faut
différencier les jeunes en fait on a les
jeunes actifs ou le coup sont nombreux à
voter pour marine le pen
en revanche les très jeunes les très
jeunes pardon donc ceux qui ont moins de
25 ans le vote plutôt à gauche et
notamment écologistes et ça c'est
quelque chose qu'on a beaucoup vu
d'ailleurs lors du précédent scrutin
pour les européennes où la jeunesse
s'est davantage mobilisée et elle a
davantage voté pour les listes et pour
les candidats pardon écologie donc on
sait que la jeunesse les très jeunes
votent plutôt à gauche qui sont
davantage concernés par la thématique
environnementale et que deux fêtes
lorsqu'ils votent à gauche ils ont
tendance à voter notamment écologistes
avoir justement si ça se confirmera pour
la présidentielle mais c'est justement
et ça sera l'un des enjeux pour la
gauche et notamment pour les écologistes
d'arriver à mobiliser ses jeunes pour
justement espérer faire un bon score au
premier tour
est ce qu'on a pu analyser et décrypter
pourquoi ces jeunes se mobilisent
davantage pour des élections européennes
que pour des régionales est ce qu on a
déjà des explications qui se dessine
alors le scrutin européen avait été
fortement médiatisée il avait beaucoup
été question d'environnement il est
finalement les jeunes lorsqu'on en parle
de sujets de préoccupation qui les
intéresse ils vont voter après encore
une fois attention il y avait qu un
jeune sur deux qui s'étaient mobilisés
donc ce n'était pas non plus un
raz-de-marée raz-de-marée de la
participation deuxième élément aussi
avoir en tête c'est que finalement
aujourd'hui ce que l'on constate dans un
certain nombre d'études et c'était
d'ailleurs l'objet et ça a été l'objet
de plusieurs débats cette semaine c'est
que finalement les jeunes leur
participation au monde politique ne
passe plus uniquement par le vote
et c'est ça qui est extrêmement
intéressant c'est à dire que pendant un
certain nombre d'années a pas moins
politisés exactement ils sont pas moins
politisés simplement l'expression de
leur engagement ou l'expression de leurs
de leurs idéaux de leur projet
finalement passe pas d'autres d'autres
biais d'autres canaux des pétitions des
manifestations et on le voit tous les
côtés on a pu le voir pour avec les
marches pour le climat on a pu le voir
avec les manifestations contre le
mariage pour tous on a pu le voir sur
tout un tas de sujets aux finalement
c'est plus aujourd'hui le vote qui
suffit à exprimer un engagement
politique bien au contraire
parce qu'on a le sentiment finalement
qu'on pourra peut-être davantage changer
les choses
en manifestant signant une pétition qu
en allant mettre un bulletin dans une
urne
si vous nous rejoignez nous sommes
toujours en direct sur lefigaro.fr et
sur la page youtube du figaro donc la
page figaro live depuis maintenant
presque trois quarts d'heure pour
décrypter
augmenter les résultats définitifs du
second tour des élections régionales
je suis donc avec eddy vautrin du maine
qui est directeur des études à
l'institut de sondage qu'amd public
on va revenir du coup sûr ces régionales
et vous disiez tout à l'heure qu'il faut
pas faire il faut pas vraiment croire
les chiffres il faut pas faim faut faire
attention à la manipulation des chiffres
etc
mais quand même ça permet de dégager des
dynamiques
est-ce que là on peut un peu résumé que
quels sont les dynamiques qui
apparaissent après ce scrutin
alors je pense que l'abstention reste
quand même l'enseignement majeur donc
c'est finalement les français ne se sont
pas mobilisés parce que ils ne sont pas
intéressés à ce scrutin ne voyons pas
l'impact ça pourrait avoir ça c'est le
premier point le deuxième point c'est
que finalement elle est d'abord et puis
le ps dans ce moment de mesures résiste
donc concrètement l'ancien monde n'est
pas complètement mort il surtout dans
les territoires on l'a vu aux
municipales ça se confirme la aux
régionales et puis enfin puis sans doute
le troisième élément c'est que
finalement ce duel qu'on annonce
constamment pour 2022 la réplique en
marche le rn finalement il peine à
s'installer dans les territoires et ipn
a finalement correspondre aux
aspirations des français avec la
république en marche mais aussi
finalement le rn qui pourtant est plus
ancien qui n'arrivent pas à s'implanter
localement et territoires qui n'arrive
pas à créer une dynamique autour d'eux
et donc à remporter des exécutifs locaux
la question qui se pose maintenant c est
ce que il va y avoir pas une si vous
voulez un phénomène de vases
communicants entre cette absence de
dynamique au niveau local et la
prochaine élection présidentielle
alors que pour l'instant on avait
vraiment deux univers distincts et
plutôt perméable une vie politique
locale ou finalement l air et le ps
résiste très bien et une vie politique
nationale ou la république en marche et
le rn s'opposent hélas pour l'instant
c'était encore assez 10 juin et assez
est assez étanche
la question qui se pose est ce que
finalement les déconvenues de l ère de
la réplique aux mains cependant et du r
n vont impacter la dynamique au niveau
national pour la prochaine
présidentielle
si j'ai une dernière une dernière
question toujours pour revenir à
l'abstention puisque c'est vraiment le
grand enseignement à tirer de ce scrutin
est ce que finalement le vote colère le
vote contestation qui était autrefois le
vote est reine c'est désormais
l'abstention finalement en partie oui
en partie oui si les français vont pas
voter c'est parce que si justement et
quand je disais il ya presque une
abstention militante c'est aussi pour
exprimer cet état d'esprit là après il
faut quand même pas minorer les
résultats du reste on nationale le
rassemblement national il reste élevé
simplement il arrive pas si vous voulez
a amplifié sa dynamique électorale
mais effectivement aujourd'hui il ya une
partie du vote antico antisystème colère
qui va soit dans l'abstention soit dans
le rassemblement national
merci edit vautrin du maine merci
d'avoir été avec nous pour ces 45
minutes en direct sur lefigaro.fr et sur
notre page youtube figaro live j'espère
que vous avez apprécié ce direct
j'espère que nous avons répondu à toutes
vos questions merci à vous tous qui
était dans le chat est notamment
jean-michel marx et bernard bon sens qui
ont posé de nombreuses questions sur le
chat du figaro.fr je vous retrouve très
vite pour un prochain direct et
n'oubliez pas de regarder le figaro.fr
pour tous les décryptages politique de
ce scrutin
à bientôt